[Musica]
io sono un giullare chiaramente non ho
sempre fatto il giullare una professione
abbastanza insolita infatti non è che
quando sono nato la mia mamma ha visto
nella cul
mi ha detto che faccia simpatica li farò
fare il giullare no
anch'io come tutti quanti noi sono stato
sottratto da quel coacervo di problemi
psicologici che è la famiglia è invece
mandato in quel luogo di coercizione
tortura che è la scuola a scuola cosa mi
hanno insegnato l'amore per la
conoscenza il libero pensiero
no la competizione con gli altri bambini
del resto è questo che fa la scuola
neoliberista io ero molto bravo e molto
competitivo
la faccio breve sostanzialmente sono
stato bravo a scuola ho vinto delle
borse di studio sono andato a studiare
in università direi prestigiose nel giro
di poco
mi hanno preso subito a lavorare come
consulente per un'importante azienda una
importante società che si occupa di
transazioni finanziarie in giro per il
mondo
dunque una decina d'anni fa mi trovavo
in costa d'avorio
in particolare mi trovavo ad abidjan
sapete che la capitale della costa
d'avorio si chiama yamoussoukro io
invece ero ad avviso anche alla capitale
economica dove si fanno gli affari
infatti è l'unica città diciamo
veramente un po conosciute della costa
d'avorio
mi trovavo la perché all'epoca gestivo
alcuni affari legati al traffico dei
rifiuti
sapete che sul traffico dei rifiuti cioè
un business miliardario cioè si muovono
un sacco di soldi il traffico totalmente
legale è ovviamente dei rifiuti
io mi trovavo la appunto per concludere
un affare e devo dire fare affari nel
terzo mondo mi piaceva molto all'epoca
perché mentre qua in europa quando fai
un affare da qualche milione di euro a
una decina di milioni di euro gli
incontri funzionari di medio livello
nel terzo mondo completamente differente
incontri direttamente presidenti sindaci
assessori
perciò il ricordo molto bene la scena
che abbiamo fatto per la conclusione
dell'affare l'abbiamo fatta sulla
terrazza panoramica dell'hilton di
abidjan
una scena straordinario pantagruelica
veramente con champagne oste che ogni
ben di dio e io ero molto felice ero
molto felice sono andate a letto molto
felice e mi sono svegliato ancor più
felice perché pensavo a quanti soldi
avrei guadagnato da quell affare e alla
promozione che di lì a poco mi sarebbe
toccata perciò la mattina
decido di prendermela libera decido di
farmi una bella passeggiata per il
mercato di ha bisogno il mercato di ha
bisogno è un labirinto un dedalo di
stradine di terra battuta e pareti di
lamiera e dove vengono vendute ogni
genere di mercanzia di un po più povera
mi ricordo proprio all'ingresso è come
entrare non varcare una nebbia di odori
ecco mi ricordo l'odore del mango del
cardamomo dell'amenità e anche della
frutta matura marcia anche ai bordi
delle strade non c'erano le fogne entro
erano circa le 10 del mattino e verso le
dieci e cinque mi ero già smarrito
all'interno del mercato di abidjan e
decido insomma faccio questa passeggiata
acquisto qualche oggetto verso le 11
un'oretta dopo camminavo sulla mia
strada e incrocio una strada diciamo
perpendicolare per puro caso giro a
sinistra il sole era più o meno a
quell'altezza erano all'incirca le 11
proprio nel momento in cui ho voltato
l'angolo anche a una decina di metri di
distanza ha voltato l'angolo un ragazzo
sapete quando vedete qualcosa con la
coda dell'occhio no e si ritorna te
perché c'è qualcosa che non va infatti
questo ragazzo pur avendo 15 16 17 anni
in su ma era grandicello gattonava
allora guardo meglio
in realtà non è che gattonava in realtà
era talmente deformato che per camminare
aveva bisogno di tavolette di legno
legate alle braccia e alle gambe e si
trascinava così per il mercato di a
bisogna chiedere l'elemosina
quando mi ha visto chiaramente io ero
bianco evidentemente più ricco che ciò
mi ha subito intercettato per farmi
l'elemosina me ne sarei voluto andare ma
ci siamo incrociati con lo sguardo e mi
ha fatto un bel sorriso ampio generoso
che mi ha inchiodato sul posto perciò
rimango fermo lui viene gli do qualche
spicciolo e poi fatalmente quella
mattina vi chiedo ma che ti è successo e
lui mi racconta la sua storia mi
racconta che quando era nella pancia
della mamma la mamma per guadagnarsi da
vivere andava nella discarica di abidjan
a raccogliere plastica e perché c'è un
piccolo commercio
di persone che prendono la plastica
nelle discariche la rivendono che la
mamma faceva quello ma fatalmente nella
discarica di abidjan come in tante altre
discariche del terzo mondo
c'erano anche i rifiuti radioattivi
degli ospedali europei e quindi lui come
molti altri è nato così mi racconta la
sua storia e lui era per terra ea un
certo punto mi sono reso conto non
riuscivo a vederlo devo togliermi le
lacrime abbondanti dagli occhi ma non
piangevo per pietà non avevo pietà di
lui sebbene la sua condizione fosse
miserrima è che in quel momento ho
capito che se lui era in quella
condizione era causa anche mia
o meglio che la mia ricchezza generava
quel tipo di miseria lui vedendo che io
stavo piangendo ha cercato quasi di
cambiare discorso come se avesse parlato
troppo oltretutto io avrei voluto dire
mille cose avrei voluto raccontare la
mia vita come mai ero lì in costa
d'avorio ma insomma le cose che volevo
dire erano davvero troppe sono salite
tutti insieme nella bocca si sono
aggrovigliate non non sono riuscito a
fare altro che farfugliare dicendogli
guarda scusa e lui mi ha detto ma non
scusarti tu sei giovane
sei bianco hai le gambe vai vai dalla
sua gente racconta racconta quello che
hai visto così magari un giorno queste
cose smetteranno di accadere questa cosa
che mi ha detto ma estremamente colpito
perciò per farla breve sono tornato dall
albergo ho fatto i bagagli ho preso il
primo volo per l'italia e quando sono
atterrato ho deciso che da quel momento
in poi avrei fatto il giullare che sarei
andato nelle piazze nelle strade a
incontrare le persone farle ridere e
raccontare questa storia nella speranza
che un giorno questa ingiustizia finirà
ora in costa d'avorio io avevo
incontrato l'orrore del mondo nonché in
europa da noi
l'orrore della disuguaglianza e della
povertà non ci sia ma il mio stile di
vita il fatto che il mio migliore
sociale mi teneva al riparo dal vedere
certe cose che invece in costa d'avorio
mi sono arrivate potentemente in faccia
come
schiaffo e ho capito ho capito in quel
momento che avrei insomma che avrei
dovuto parlarne che il mondo così non
può andare avanti ecco che il fatto che
per la ricchezza e il benessere di pochi
debbano soffrire in molti sembra la
realizzazione di una distopia non è
certamente il mondo che vorrei
ritengo che per essere liberi e felici
devono essere anche gli altri
quindi ho deciso di parlare di questo io
lì in costa d'avorio ha incontrato come
la manifestazione un episodio a
dimensione umana del colonialismo
il fatto cioè che i paesi più ricchi e
più potenti militarmente vanno a
impoverire altri paesi per sottrarre
ricchezza e proprio beneficio di questo
sebbene sia incredibile probabilmente
pensare che i miei spettacoli siano
comici nei miei spettacoli comici in
realtà parlo di questo ma oggi oggi non
vorrei parlare dei miei spettacoli
vorrei parlare di un progetto di un
progetto differente e che ritengo più
interessante perché coinvolge centinaia
di persone in giro per l'europa è nato
durante la pandemia nato perché la
difficoltà del tempo mi ha messo di
fronte all'impossibilità di fare
spettacolo di fronte all'impossibilità
di andare a trovare il pubblico che ho
dovuto cercare un'alternativa per
portare avanti il mio discorso e l'aiuto
me l'hanno offerto le tecnologie non
offerto le possibilità di internet dei
social grazie all'utilizzo delle
tecnologie ho potuto mettermi in
connessione con altre persone in italia
con altre persone in europa con persone
che in qualche modo sono mosse da una
comune sensibilità ci siamo messi
insieme abbiamo generato questo progetto
è un progetto che si chiama face the
wall e riguarda il tema delle migrazioni
c'è qualcosa che ritengo e che riteniamo
particolarmente odioso il fatto cioè che
quando le persone che sono impoverite da
le guerre le carestie i mutamenti
climatici dovuti al colonialismo o
quantomeno in cui il colonialismo ha
inciso peggiorando la situazione
ecco quando queste persone cercano
scappare e di trovare un futuro migliore
altrove
e quando poche decine di migliaia di
questi milioni di persone impoverite
riescono arrivare ai confini dell'europa
trovano un muro trovano una europa
sempre più intenta a innalzare barriere
su una stupida retorica dell'invasione
su una stupida retorica del noi contro
di loro
poche decine di migliaia di persone
stanno mettendo in mostra le
contraddizioni di un europa che si
farebbe si configurerebbe come la patria
dei diritti umani e che poi questi
diritti umani non rispetta lasciando che
centinaia di persone muoiano in mare
uomini donne bambini
ecco questo per noi è particolarmente
odioso perciò abbiamo deciso di creare
un progetto artistico che sia da un lato
un progetto di memoria ma dall'altro
anche un progetto di denuncia
abbiamo deciso di mettere le nostre
facce in senso proprio letterale abbiamo
messo a punto una tecnica per realizzare
calchi in gesso dei nostri volti e
abbiamo deciso di prestare
collettivamente i nostri volti per
queste persone che hanno perso la vita e
che le politiche di chiusura europee
hanno progressivamente invisibili dato
il nostro non è un gesto di
appropriazione dell'identità di queste
persone non vogliamo sostituirci a loro
non vogliamo metterci sullo stesso piano
e chiaro che c'è un piano differente noi
siamo estremamente più privilegiati ma
vogliamo segnalare con un gesto di cura
verso questi corpi morti e abbandonati
un gesto di cura che si ispira al gesto
di antigone che va a seppellire il corpo
di suo fratello
vogliamo testimoniare fratellanza
vicinanza unione il fatto che non siamo
poi così distanti il fatto che nel
momento in cui muoiono loro anche una
parte di noi muore
allora centinaia di persone in giro per
l'europa hanno aderito decine e decine
di persone in varie città ognuna sta
mettendo il proprio volto con l'idea che
poi
queste calchi queste maschere che stiamo
realizzando sbuchino sulle mura delle
varie città che aderiscono le maschere
che sono in questo momento dietro di me
sono solo una piccola parte un piccolo
esempio
questo è il 3 ottobre sbucheranno nelle
varie città perché i corpi lasciati
insepolti poi si trasformano in fantasmi
e questi fantasmi
ecco appariranno sulle mura della città
il 3 ottobre perché perché è
l'anniversario della strage di lampedusa
quando nel 2013 quasi 400 persone
morirono a mezzo miglio nautico dalla
costa
proprio là dove le persone vanno a fare
il bagno ecco 370 persone che scappavano
dalla guerra
in particolare erano quasi tutte
provenienti dal corno d'africa morirono
è stato il primo evento mediatico su
questo tema e noi vogliamo ricordarlo
facendo apparire questi fantasmi in giro
per le città europee a testimonianza che
una memoria c'è è la testimonianza che
qualcuno ci sta mettendo la faccia che
non sono dimenticati a testimonianza che
per creare un mondo di felicità e di
ricchezza devono esserlo tutti vecchi e
felici per cui noi stiamo mettendo la
faccia
ecco vi chiediamo mettetelo anche voi
grazie